hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be taking a look at the
samsung galaxy s3's design if you didn't
already know the samsung galaxy s3 was
recently released the other day it has a
quad-core processor it's running android
4.0 with touchwiz on top it's got a huge
4.8 inch display it's a beautiful device
in a lot of ways but the thing that
people are talking about the most is the
way it looks actually a lot of people
think it looks really bad now i'm going
to reserve my own personal judgments
about how it looks and how it feels in
the hand for the day that i'm actually
holding it and hopefully i can give you
guys a full review so thumbs up if you
want to see that but until then let's go
ahead and give you what i found to be a
pretty interesting analysis of why it
looks the way it does you can thank
apple for this one let's take a closer
look
this is probably an image you've seen on
the internet before on april 18th 2011
apple sued samsung for the galaxy s1
looking too much like their iphone and
this is what they sued samsung for
copying word for word a rectangular
product shape with all four corners
uniformly rounded
the front surface of the product being
dominated by a screen with black borders
as to the iphone and ipod touch products
substantial black borders above and
below the screen having roughly equal
width and narrower black borders on
either side of the screen having roughly
equal width a display of a grid of
colorful icons with uniformly rounded
corners and a bottom row of square icons
set from the other icons that do not
change as the pages of the interface are
viewed so let's break these down one by
one so now it's 2012 and the samsung
galaxy s3 has been revealed and you can
see the work of samsung lawyers just
crawling all over this device starting
with the rectangular product shape you
can see that samsung has clearly made it
more of an oval definitely not the
rectangle that the iphone is and the
corners aren't even uniformly rounded
anymore the bottom corners are tighter
than the top corners of this device and
apple also mentioned the front being
dominated by a screen with the black
borders ha not so here no black borders
here just pebble blue and marble white
nothing to see here and what's that
apple also said that their top and
bottom borders have equal width samsung
lawyers said we got this and they gave
it a chin what's good and they also
mentioned that apple had colorful square
icons so you may have noticed the newest
version of touchwiz has done away with
those icon backgrounds that made them
all square and colorful and that row of
square icons that stays persistent at
the bottom that apple calls a dock that
is gone too in touchwiz so boom there
you have it the samsung galaxy s3
designed by lawyers in california so
there you go guys that's the explanation
now you know go ahead and give it a
thumbs up if you learned something so
yeah what do you guys think of the new
galaxy f3 design personally like i said
at the beginning i kind of want to wait
till i get my hands on the device before
i judge it so hopefully when we have
that full review i'll be able to tell
you guys exactly how it looks and feels
in the hand uh but yeah that other
company you know make sure you share
this video so people actually know what
to be complaining about maybe you don't
want to complain to samsung as much as
you want to complain to that other
company i mean rectangular devices
really either way like i said thanks for
watching this video i appreciate it if
you like the rest of my videos or other
videos in this series let me know and go
ahead and subscribe if you haven't
already and i'll talk to you guys in the
next video
peace
you